SometimesYou just got to step back and ask
yourself.
What am I doingLike what am I. Doing.
No really like
Nine out of 10 times someone ate hmos so we
don't go in on one screen
And that's the captain heyLooking. At all.
Weekend a lot of many projectsOne.
WhiteAnd I working.
I don't want to hand it to you cuz I might
drop it
Are you going to send a message to yourselfA
synonym message to cell.
Phone
Going on running man having time I guess you
got some stuff you dealing with
I found a couple steps in the stomach
These men just finally figured a way to hang
that thing out their window
Bad everybody do nothing let's go to the
DiscordLet's see what he said.
I mean so we already knew that they were
only cleaning up the messes that they were
making
And let's see what kind of status updates
we've been getting from the agents
I need you to figure out how to get the real
twitch code you didn't get the right oneThe
right switch code starts with 08.
Are you
What I need you never to do when I'm
correcting you is tell me no because I've
already done the math added the equations in
that shit was wrong
And like I said you got the wrong ones
Is wrong with youQuestioning me.
And the problem is that she didn't even try
to see how I was right just to instantly
assumed I was wrong
That's the real problem
Oh my God it's so much stuff
Actually that's why
It's supposed to beThat ain't what it's
supposed to be there.
And steep of itI don't want nothing.
We're not deep blocking the templates
We about to get all the errors
And see the gold Minds oh this is the gold
mines are outdated because we've started to
have the agents and Lord help me okay
But somebody's got to take the risks so that
everybody doesn't have to take a risk okay I
had to be the guy to stand in front of the
bullet so nobody had to stand in front of
the Smoking Gun anymore
However
Gold Mine discoveries is pretty cool
For details huh
That's the ones they want me to add to
everything right there they want me to add
the dream ball which is the application that
lets me take my church EBT projects I'm
sorry conversations and give them to the AI
agent and I started expanding that in a way
where we'll be able to use our conversations
to train up agent that we should be able to
talk to so I'm hoping that from there I'm
able to create a software as a solution
company based off of
Like a creature on AI by character and it
could be you so like Ari but Carmen but
Charlie but Victor but
That'll be an interesting project to push
forward I really put it on the back shelf
cuz it's not something I'm really interested
in but it's definitely a fun project
contract leads that was a good project that
one right there I was scraping off of
Twitter Instagram or whatever social media I
could find and this is all before I knew
about Shadow bands right but boy I was I was
a gray head on their service man I'll tell
him I'll dancing on that shit they didn't
even know I was there
Make me feel like I was at a hacker
And all cuz I'm in all cuz I knew about
Library called undetected Chrome driver
crazy right
But either way
The way that that project works is it scans
online for opportunities for us to make
money with my coding skills and then the
goal was to have it automate The Collection
like every aspect of the lead generation
And then we have agent cell phone V1
Boy we had to live there project go I ain't
going to lie that bitch you got thick it got
thick fast and you know you like a big woman
you do not like a thick project they get
hard-headed so I had to let it go and start
over but I mean
We're here now because of that right and to
be honest with you
Agent cell phone V1 isn't even the V1 of the
agent cell phone well I made this project
like 20 times at this point
Okay so you know I had to go and make a
ideas repo cuz
Is repo cuz once I finally get my swarm up
and running I'm going to give them things
like that and just tell him go cray cray
Yeah and that's all my little ideas a lot of
it what it ends up turning out to be is cuz
I find I have a little cheat code with pyqt
5 and pretty much bobcoding so like I use
bobcoding to handle the back end and I'll
make sure everything works via test and
actual practical use and then what I'll do
is I'll have the agent wire that up to a
pyqt 5 to give it a actual dashboard because
you know normal humans don't like typing
into command lines they like clicky buttons
Either way I'll pretty much set that up as a
quick littlePrototyping Laboratory.
And then we haveWe have my favorite project
of all time the project scanner.
The project scanner is my first big project
it's the only project to ever be like by
multiple people it's actually got two stars
And it's actually been like it's actually
people have found use out of it so I created
something that people actually use it ain't
a lot of people but still the fact that you
know in a world where I'm not doing any kind
of marketing
In a world where I'm not doing nearly enough
marketing
Two people sought out what I built
And it ain't right no complaints yet
It's been so long since I worked on that
project the last thing I remember is trying
to add a feature to allow it to be able to
run through your GitHub and then create ooh
if we did I would die if not then I need to
pin this on my board cuz I sure want to add
it but I would like the ability for the
As well as because we already have the
ability for it to go through your GitHub
repo and then actually initiate a project
scan the project scanner just turns the
project into an AST it pretty much does rag
for the for the company I mean for the llms
so it's shortens down what they need to the
bear meeting bones and allows them to
instead of handing it at 6,500
About project I can hand it 16,000 line
Jason and I'm not to say that you know
$16,000 line Jason is you know good it by
any metric but you know when when the
projects get is complex and it's complicated
and it's just crazy as some of mine is
getting gotten then that's actually nothing
Listen lastly
I didn't really care about the patterns that
it said I'm pretty sure this has something
to do with coding and that that's something
for their personal back in
But I was proud to see that
Almost all of the Discord buttons work the
only one that doesn't only one that doesn't
work is the templates right now and I still
haven't tried pieces yet so let's see what
pieces this
What do you mean this piece of being
implementedThis is unacceptable.
This is UN
Acceptable oh is that my boy Blaze my blades
my blah Blaze my boy Blaze bling bling boy
Sharing stories and shitOh shit.
That boy at the God damn look at you
touching grassI'm so proud of you.
No Crystal you're not allowed to do a ttdrb
teach ttrb you know what I'm trying to say a
ttrpg
All rightSo. No. I need to.
Go back to cam mode cuz we didBecause we did
the death blog. The bloggity blog blog.
Oh no we didn't
Cuz the original reason why I went here was
to go to agent force channel so that I can
read the last post
And now it's irritating me cuz they didn't
even postedGot me out here looking for
something that don't exist. You know you
want these.
Kendrick Lamar
And you know stuff for the sweet chicken I
can't log in
Why would I know it when you set him up
And now you blocked me out rightThis step
part where I get the frustration and that
attitude.
And then the no resultsAnd I just go look it
up and figure that shit out later.
You started with attitude so I just
responded with the same
I'm never going to care what your reason for
giving me attitude is
Cuz the world doesn't give a fuck to Victor
had a bad day
You live in a world where they're going to
tell you they care about yoursBut they don't
mean that shit.
Black
After you drop my price
Leave me alone
Can I tell you whatWake up. No.
You know I'm really interested in how the
fireplace looks
Even showcase to the world like on some
stuff like like I'll be showing out this
window like the room don't go all the way
around
No I'm sayingOh no.
Like a mountain bikes
Do it like that I could have just did it
like this like yeah this is what we watching
Oh man that would actually be like
Like wait
No I'm not going to lie I'm fascinatedIt
might be coming soon.
All right but do we see the Christmas
treeYeah I see that tree. It's a tree over
there.
And then my question really becomeFireplace.
Is that fireplace going to look badass when
I light it
I know you're in just passed no gasThat
better not have been what I thought it was.
That's itIt's a good day to light the fire.
It's a good day to lie to furSo we going to
lie at first.
Got a problem with me like the firstWhat
happened to the evening.
It's got to be enoughFor now.
You said hi
Lumpy's charcoal
Oh datum when I get them both
Didn't work like I wanted
And I blame you I for letting my fire grow
upMy fire will never supposed to go out.
I told youI'm supposed to be able to. Burn
the whole house down. One of these lost.
Otherwise it ain't no real first
On my dick
You must not
Have
Yeah
Ouija
No it's cold
Your mom never takes anybody says she made
it safeNo that's not a big.
That's straight it ain't just me it's mama
daddy period me and hehe thanks you said I'm
going to text me I might even be the guy
text me when you get there
And not even check to see if you text me
when you got there
Okay I think I think we got it first I think
we got it first
OkaySpeak now.
It starts with oauth
Did you type that into chat
What did they say did you read it or you
skimmed over it
What
About itSo if there's no twitch token yet.
And I'm saying we need one
You see what I'm saying on how I always have
to give you to give you that I got to give
you the airplane treatment
And if you wasn't saying it in a way where
you was looking for help then you would have
been proactively thinking
No you were telling me so that I did thatAnd
that's what I've been saying I have a
problem with.
At some point you got to start answering the
question
I had said that I had asked y'all to take
the wood out the strip
To which y'all had only took out twoEach.
And I was like I don't think that's fair cuz
I feel like that's the bare minimumEven less
than 30.
Don't know if I want to talk chilling in the
truck
No
You waited for me to get back for the
tokenOh okay.
So you're waiting on me
Okay good cuzWhen I talk to you the phone.
Damn it I wasn't here to assist you.
I'm rolling upThat's what I'm doing.
But the computer is available while I'm
doing that if you need to find the EnV file
Say that againNo no continue.
Well I think it's because I don't think
I didn't
I don't think you supposed to do that cuz I
think you could like people could see it
exactly
Don't trust nobody yeah second is because I
thought the street
But make sure you close DMV before
You finish so that when I get out I don't
forget and I expose myself to the world
Where is the EMB file and I'll click here
And then nothing
ForeverOkay cuz the Envy is in the root of
the file.
The routeGot it.
Imagine you went through each one of the
It's two different locations where it could
have been inJust for default.
The rootAnd.
A folder that says configBut since we don't
have that.
Or you didn't see it there it was in the
roofThat's the main place you'll see it is
the route.
But somePeople like to be. Super.
Organized and shit
I think
I think I used it like crazy
Have you asked the agent what the
What it's looking for in the EMV for the
twitch
Or no you just going to guess
If you just randomly put it in there
That agents can't even see him
Not negatively they have to find weird ways
to do they canJust send.
What are you looking for me as far as
whatThat's a broad question.
The tokenThe token you know how many
different tokens they are. What are we
talking about.
We're talking about this we are swamp
It's a shame you don't know what you're
working onIt's a shame you don't know what
you're working on what are you working on.
No no stop typingAnswer me cuz I'm talking
to you.
What are we working on
It
So with that being said then
That's what I'm saying you keep assuming
Yes sirJust like I say trying to Bare
minimal.
Read out loud maybe I'm missing it I want
you to think out loudI want to hear the
thought process.
Kens
Also needsYour channel name. Doesn't let you
see formats.
Okay
Which access first then falls back
You think by reading what they said
I'm asking you what you was thinking first
right
Right and then as far as thinking goes right
there was a part where you thought that
Did you say that part out loud
You said that you was going to do that
because if you lie again I'm going to pop
you in the face for playing me cuz I'm not
playing
Cuz I did say I want to hear them thoughts
right right then I hear you start reading
Completely understand that
Now cuz when I gave you the chance to say
what you doing what you was thinking about
or you didn't say shit
Yes sirThat's what I'm saying.
But once again you're free to say what you
know now
I'm looking for the twitch access code for
search that's fine
It's a control app button at the top and if
they told me exactly what I was supposed to
type in there ain't no way I'm going to miss
it
Then we're going to take 30 seconds to
realize we typed on the wrong keyboard
And then we're going to do it againThen
we're going to do it again.
My baby dumb my baby dumb as hellBoy this
dumb as hell.
She didn't realize you typing on the wrong
computer
Twitch bar and
They don't have it so we have to add it so
that lets you know that that's where we
thought they were that's what they were
supposed to be looking for but this is not
what they're looking for maybe now when I
see this it makes me wonder
What's looking for this because this was
what it was supposed to be looking for
Does that exist do we need to fix that cuz
that's a another loop just running around
unended
Don't dare close out a loop and leave six
loops on ended
What do you mean what we looking for they
got twitch form boy major update twitch
You can ask that agent go look through the
code for switch swarm voice major update
twitch fight if nothing pop up what does
that mean
NoIf nothing pops up we need to switch those
out and delete them.
And maybe that's why the twitch by don't
work right now
But I'd like to hurry and pass through this
quickly I don't want this to be all we did
Cuz we only did sites that Jason for the the
website deployer
I would like to at least try to finish that
on coding dayBut.
I know how that goes
Oh that fire going boy
Then I said it and she sit there looking
stupid as fuck so I have to smack her right
OhNo one I'm already irritated with you boy
you better stop playing with me.
Making me madCome on computer.
And I hosting on her to get upDid you did
you type what I asked you to do.
What did I ask you to do to go through that
file and look for the twitch though we are
swamped which box
BecauseThe two things.
Cuz it literally went one year right out the
fucking upYou just like listened and didn't
hear me.
Write the fucking front of me
Which means you're working inefficientlyAnd
waste them fucking time.
But go ahead
I don't know if it's even with me repeating
it because it ain't like like I told you
directly what to do I said literally what to
do
And you still took off and did whatAnswer.
I told her to go to the file but I didn't
say go through about if you listen to what I
said I gave direct instructions on what the
fuck needed to be done
So either you're not listeningOr you suck at
taking Direction it's one of the two.
Cuz I said as we scroll back down let's
scroll back down let's repeat
ourselvesAgain.
For the record how do I feel about
repeatsCommon occurrence with you though.
You knowYou know what common occurrence
means. It means it happens all the time.
Those two things that we were looking atAre
the old switch box.
Just told you when you didn't fucking hear
me
And they're not right
But the point is that if we have that in
there somewhere along the line somebody said
hey this the twitch
Look for it when you look for thisRight and
why would somebody do that are you.
We put something in the fucking DMV files
just so we can find it
Why would we put the switch
By in hereBecause all. The rest of the Tok.
Ens in here cuz tokens could be anywhere
right
So why do we have any tokens in the envy
Because that's a dumb answer to me bro
You're giving me the obviously answers
Yes sirWhy would we put anything in the EMB
file.
What does any of these codes get used
forSocial media.
What about this right here
Cuz you said specifically social media right
so all that's for social media
Oh okay then it can't be that answer right
that must be too specific rightSo then that
sounds like a stupid answer.
Yes sir you put all the stuff in the MV file
for social mediaWhy do we put stuff in the
NBA.
Because
Why is it weird to go right
Yes sir right so it was working on a twitch
but right
And we neededA twitch by token.
We would then put the twitch by token in the
EMV file right and why did we do that
Is that where the bus
It's a secure place for it to go I can get
ignored that's a pretty decent place
SoTo answer the question for you. As usual.
It's because you planned on using it in a
project you were making
So if they planned on using that in a
project they were making right
It might be a project that somebody was
making
So instead of making a whole new project
That shit lead to another project
We should only have one twitch by project in
the twitch by project rightYes sir so Dad
can you see why that's important to know.
You see why I assumed you'd be able to
figure that out
Especially with the fact that I said itStep
by step I said.
Put that shit in there ask him to look
through the code to find itI sent it.
So yeah
I'll be done by theThink about that.
You about to spend another 45 minutes on
some shit out of being done withAnd call you
something then you going to say you help me.
Did you really help it
You done thanks appreciate itBye.
The only one I got
Or too much from you
I know that was all your energy right there
I didn't ask you way too much
Had to readHad to remember had to be able to
type.
Has never fit for yourself
While we stopped earlyCuz it's not going to
get no better.
Pick something
Where you put it is they gave you two
different forms they gave you the answer at
the top already I already told you what to
do with the two listed
What I'm saying it is before you do anything
there and confuse yourself you should do
what I already told you to do
Let me go immediately because just make
three
You should not be able to copy that and
bring it over there you might have to just
type the first part of it you don't need the
actual code part you just need the part it's
looking for
Like all that the blue part yeah okayCuz
only one part of that is.
The code the other part is the idea
That's how the code finds it you could
literally put that you could copy that right
there then go up to the top and go to the
little search thing and type that in and
find all the pots the spots in the project
where they're using it
And I'm asking you to ask the agent to do
that
And once again do not take that in there
In this phone rightFind the thing in this
phone.
What you're thinking if you spoke out loud
Every file
To make sure that
Today shouldThat nobody's like he was in
that. Cuz you said that's old.
No why would you say make sure nobody's
using you you want to go find all the
instances where they're using it
But no I don't want them to or not to be I'm
unboxed I want to find
Everything they got out there that include
that
And I won't know what to do until we find
out
Does that make sense explain to me why that
makes sense
BecauseYou said we need to follow.
It sound like you just said that to drive
just say that and that's my fucking problem
If I'm not supposed to paste it how would it
how was it supposed to see what we're
talking about
What did you say
No I'm asking what did you type oh major
underscore update underscore switchbot and
then I'll send you the same thing for this
So they can find
She said major underscore update under
Everything I asked where I'm not getting
Even after the resetEven after I'm trying to
beat you.
What did you typeFind this and everything.
Major underscore update underscore switch
underscore botAnd then I can't put the.
We only need to identifiers like what's the
problem with it
Nothing
We're over there
So for having a walk to go get it
Your family get through my food on the
floorFor everyone.
It say no matches for major underscore
updateAnd any file.
What I found instead is Major under yes
stuff that doesn't say that
It says what I found instead was Major
underscore update underscore reporting
protocol.md
Post major updates that people and just
major
And then it says possible explanations it's
Theron doesn't exist in the cold base and
it's in a foul like Envy but I checked Envy
related files
It's name differentlyLike major switch.
Or you could just press delete
Okay I'm sorryIt's no way you thought that
was the way to do it.
You're going to leave the theThis part wait.
The whole thing right or do we need that for
some reason when they didn't work
The major underscore to which updates in the
twitch by Major update but I don't think we
need to delete those
If they're not connected to anything
I'm just askingAnd that they didn't work.
Of course I'm seeing one up there I
definitely I see twitch storm voice right in
front of me
What but you said you didn't see it
And now what those the what are those
About to delete something else
Even at first delete I don't know if you
deleted what you was supposed to delete
first and it looked like you might have
deleted my username for something that I
actually need
That was up there that it might have been
I'm just saying it's interesting that I see
I'm just going to say the RH passwordAnd no
RH username.
I'm highly confident when I first started I
didn't see it
That hashtag you're Robin Hood account
password it been right there
Super frustrate
I'm specifically took the time to say I'mma
just say
IngDentist near me I'm going to smack.
Christmas. And ignoring.
Yes
Cuz I'm more so tripping up how I said I'm
upset
RH passwordThen this just come. And say.
Robin Hood.
Because if you lookAt that other screen over
there. Look at that screen look at the other
screen. You see it.
You see how it says everything I say
Oh I have to put the rest of the dots
together for youNo sir.
And why I said RHAnd why I'm upset that you
said.
RobinhoodAgain.
Evil asked me what to do nextPretty much.
I think I know what to do now
I think I'm supposed toAdd the token now.
Right here underneath this oneNow cuz
there's something right.
Now
CurrentQuestion mark.
Organizationally right
But I meanNo no I guess I'm specific.
I guess I'm particularly
To JacksonLike that.
And then you added there or I guess not
supposed to be are you asking me cuz if you
are it literally say
O a u t h like the one I've been told youAnd
then it say you're talking here.
That's what I'm saying like you literally
cut brain off sometime stay online
No sir that shit is not cool that shit is
embarrassing
The only because I know you better than
thatThat's why that bug me bug me.
Also did the the channel I don't know if I'm
supposed to do that butIt said it and
another channel name.
What channel is that supposed to be what
channel
I love how you think you know like you wrote
the code and understand anything there
Okay I don't know that I know so what do you
do when you don't knowExactly before you
assume you know.
Cuz who's channel is that supposed to be
what channel is that supposed to beA
different one.
I'm saying I don't knowJust like we thought
that switch bot with the answer to which
token was the answer.
Far as I know if it don't start with o u t
hThen it's wrong.
And I don't see that one starting with o u t
h
It had it at first before you deleted it
So you need to look into your password
On the other screen instead of being so
confident that you got the right shit cuz
I'm telling you that it's supposed to start
with something that I'm seeing you don't
have
IfYou're if you share.
Must match your Twitch channel name exactly
should match the account used for the old
token
Yeah I use the wheelBut they don't say.
Yes sir
To change everything
Why this token
Don't grab the OU a t h thing that I think
it's supposed to have
Is this is what I be talking about when I'll
be like you just instantly dismiss me as I'm
wrong right
When if I could just let this slide I would
have but I'm trying to inspect to see
Why is he trying to inspect to see because I
have reason to believe we need these things
Things that you're just like herI got to
talking.
Again
Nutritional doesn't come with an old appThat
screen is only for develop applications you
create.
AnythingNot for your normal Channel login
what's going on with your Twitter account
Channel your user.
Both equals a system app can use to take
used to ask switch for permission at to act
as you
An old token it's only created when a
developer app exist
You log into the app that apps for app URL
and click authorize
It says that the twitch Channel doesn't come
with also again
My question
Fuck
Ing phone
With Scopes and yeah that's the one you pay
for it says oh
The exact token typeOr.
Say it's not not because of meI think I need
you to meet.